Satellite images of the North Carolina
coastline reveal features in the landscape
scientists cannot explain.
The shapes are large and oval or egg shaped
and stretch for miles and miles.
They're everywhere, one after another after
another.
It's got to be the biggest mystery in all of
American geology.
George Howard is investigating the mysterious
structures nicknamed the Carolina Bays.
These are amazing features.
I don't know what they are.
They're low and flat and circled with a
white bay rim.
It's absolutely amazing.
Recent satellite images have only added to
the mystery.
These things are present in huge numbers.
People think that there might be half 1000000
to 2 million of them.
Despite their nickname, the Bays are not
confined to North Carolina.
Strange enough to see him in one location.
But what's crazy is when you zoom out, you
can see that they extend from Florida all the
way up the Eastern seaboard to Delaware.
You can live on them. People's houses are all
over them.
Highways go through them.
Their shopping centers around them.
George Howard is out searching for one of the
shapes.
It's more difficult than it looks.
This appears to be a white sandy rim here of
a bay.
It curves both sides to the left and the
right.
You can only see them when you're flying
overhead and that's when you get a real good
look at the strange pattern on the ground.
George is using a drone to analyze the
structure of the elliptical shapes.
To be able to get out here and actually use
some of this amazing technology to fly.
Basically robotic aerial cameras above
Carolina Bay.
It is really special.
Once airborne, the drone's camera helps to
locate his position in the egg shaped bay.
Wow. We are definitely where we thought we'd
be looking at the photography.
I think we're right on it right now.
We can see the interior choked with
vegetation in here and just a beautiful,
brilliant white sand defining the western
edge of the bay.
It's not just the existence of these egg
shapes that baffle scientists.
It's also the strange alignment.
What's so crazy about this is that they're
all stretched in the same way.
So it looks like someone took all these
circles and just kind of dragged them so that
they're all slanted in one particular way.
What's odd about this?
What's really bizarre is how do you get
ovals in the same shape and in the same
orientation as really strange?
Some experts think a clue may lie in the age
of the bays.
These shapes were created during the last
Ice Age thousands of years ago.
It's a time when.
North America was a very different place.
It's a time when ice sheets were creeping
down from the north, upwards of 10,000 feet
thick ice sheets that are equivalent to what
we would find today in Antarctica.
In this strange world of ice, prehistoric
humans lived alongside many creatures that
have long since disappeared from the earth.
Right before the end of the Ice Age.
There were amazing mammals that walked
through this very area mastodons, mammoths,
saber toothed tigers, beavers, the size of
VW bugs.
Some scientists speculate if these enormous
egg shapes are the work of giant beavers.
These beavers were like no beavers we have
today.
They were massive, probably had incisors 6
to 12 inches long, just a whole nother scale
of beaver and not something you would want
to run into out here today.
But even giant beavers would have difficulty
building dams on this scale.
I'm kind of amazed that the animals are
capable of building such uniform structures
all in the same orientation.
They all talking to each other.
It would take a lot of giant beavers to make
this many structures.
Where are all their bones instead of
beavers?
Some scientists have linked the egg shapes
to a terrifying Ice Age apocalypse.
One theory about the Carolina Bays is that
some kind of an impact hit the ice sheet and
actually blew chunks of ice down into lower
latitudes.
Giant ice bombs the size of massive icebergs
crashing down from the skies.
The thought is as terrifying as it is
bizarre.
You can only imagine if icebergs were
launched hundreds of miles from the glacial
ice sheet at hypersonic speeds.
They would have landed in this landscape and
it exploded with the force of many, many
atomic bombs.
But how could super massive ice bombs have
created the pattern we see today?
Maybe this is what happened.
If you were standing here during this event,
there would have been absolutely nothing you
could have done. You could run a mile in any
direction and you'd be still walking your way
into apocalypse.
The animals would have been wiped out.
But not everyone accepts the giant ice bomb
theory.
There's nothing that big that's going to hit
a sheet of ice and send giant ice cubes
soaring through the sky to land on the
ground hundreds of miles away to form an
impact crater. It just doesn't work.
Scientists are still unable to explain these
images.
We don't know why these shapes are here, why
they are this shape, why they are aligned in
this strange way.
We don't know what or who made them.
It's just so fascinating that there are still
things on earth, even something as abundant
and widespread as this that we just don't
have an answer to.
A weather satellite captures an image of a
deadly hurricane heading straight for the US
coastline.
It's like a freight train that's plowing
through Haiti and it is headed straight for
Florida.
But there's something especially weird and
scary about this storm.
The first time I.
Saw this image, I thought it was
Photoshopped.
Somebody was making a joke.
October 4th, 2016.
Hurricane Matthew batters the Caribbean
island of Haiti.
It starts getting over warmer and warmer
water and gathering more and more energy,
doing massive amounts of destruction.
This is Matthew.
Was the strongest storm in 50 years to hit
the country.
The damage and destruction and loss of life
is almost incomprehensible.
When it's pointed at the hell storm the goes
13 satellite captures this disturbing image.
It looks just like a skull.
This demonic looking, evil face with the eye
of the storm just as it's hitting the shore.
It looks like something straight out of the
day of the dead celebration.
The skull is captured by an infrared camera
that allows experts to analyze and track the
intensity of the storm's raging winds.
As it turns out, this is really how the storm
looked as it was making landfall in Haiti.
But the skull isn't stopping at Haiti.
It's heading straight for the United States.
Weather experts are closely monitoring the
storm as it approaches.
You're almost looking image by image every
ten or 15 minutes as the image is update to
see what's going on.
They spot something weird.
We're getting unusual radar reflections from
the calm eye of the storm.
We see some kind of radar signature.
Something is inside of that eye that
shouldn't be there.
Each color in the image represents the
density of the material inside the storm.
Darker shades indicate calmness while
violent activity is red or orange.
You're expecting just to see darkness in the
center of the hurricane.
There shouldn't be anything there, but it's
glowing green.
This gives the experts monitoring the storm a
vital clue.
When we watch a radar image like this and we
see this kind of reading, we then can
conclude that it has to be something alive.
Whatever is inside the eye is a living,
breathing creature.
As if a hurricane weren't scary enough.
Right? We've got something that might be
alive and is really big inside of it.
It blows my mind that this is possible.
What huge creature could be dragged along by
the mammoth hurricane?
And how did it get there?
Maybe the hurricane has whipped up the water
so much that it's actually sucked things out
of it and into the sky.
There is a rare meteorological phenomenon
that does vacuum up creatures from the ocean.
It's known as a waterspout.
Waterspouts are basically tornadoes over the
water.
And sure enough, there seems to be a rare
water spout attached to the skull.
Hurricane Matthew is passing the coast of
Jamaica and there are surfers on the beach as
it's going by. They take photos and they
find a waterspout that's sucking things up
right into the hurricane.
Those tornadoes are waterspouts, could
actually lift frogs or fish up into the air
and those could show up on weather radar.